a caravan of men and Giants crosses the
land they reach a moment of decision
allow a troop of thieves to join the
roving party in the hopes they might
bolster the defenses or send them away
in fear assuming they will steal
precious supplies in the Banner Saga you
face these kinds of decisions all
through the game's ten-hour campaign
making choices and then clenching your
jaw and hoping your trust was properly
placed sometimes it is and sometimes it
isn't making decisions with unclear
consequences is the banner sagas main
thrust you spend most of your time
watching a convoy of Men and Giants
cross the frigid Scandinavian landscape
and rest in the villages and encampments
they encounter the automated journey is
interrupted frequently with events that
require your input a woman has been
murdered and her mother blames another
traveler do you support the accuser do
you support the accused or do you dig
deeper into the conflict
you can't presume anything kindness can
lead to disaster harshness can lead to
triumph all you can do is follow your
instincts for the best this is an
intriguing approach to strategy and
storytelling and it often works your
convoy is made up of Klansmen members of
the giant like Varro race and human
warriors each day spent hiking uses up
supplies should you run out you start
losing followers to famine furthermore
the same resource you use to purchase
more supplies in the towns you visit is
the same resource you use to level up
your heroes who you lead him to
turn-based battle the story takes an
impressive number of turns based on your
choices weaving a twisted tapestry of
unlikely alliances and disastrous
betrayals choices might manifest
immediately or quite sometime later but
the Banner Saga never goes out of its
way to point out its own intricacies it
allows events to simply occur and as a
result the decision making process feels
ganic rather than gamy and contrived
that said there are times when I wish
there were a more obvious and consistent
connection between my decisions and the
results and by the time it had drawn to
a close the story I had co-authored had
gone off the rails a major plot point
had been almost entirely buried and
while I was moved by the ending I was
shocked when the credits rolled
immediately afterwards the main enemy
forces are made up of a marauding evil
known as the dredge battles occur on a
grid and if you've ever played a
turn-based strategy game you'll be
immediately familiar with the basics
even before combat begins you must
consider which heroes to bring to battle
choose wisely different heroes have some
different special abilities and if they
haven't recovered from the previous
battle they're less effective in this
one on the battlefield you must pay
attention to armor values as well as
health values as well as maximizing the
amount of damage you can do with any
given hero moment-to-moment
the Banner Saga skirmishes are much like
those in similar battle systems but a
rock-solid interface of fantastic
animated art style and varied abilities
keep the combat compelling though it's
rarely overtly challenging until you
near the game's final hour even more
compelling is the banner sagas
atmosphere - colourful hand-drawn
characters and cel-shaded villages would
have been at home in a high budget
animated film and the site of your
Caravan stretching across the screen
with the yellow banner flying from an ox
card on the horn viral trudging wearily
onward hammers home the viciousness of
the elements Banner Saga is a beautiful
game filled with interesting ideas and
enjoyable battles it's too bad it trips
over itself so clumsily by the end but
this chilly journey does a fine job of
reminding you that being a respectable
leader is about more than just giving
rousing speeches and making alliances
[Music]